the right to bear arms in Europe for a
few and under strict conditions car
makers and vehicle emissions in the
spotlight again and the world after
brexit somehow life moves on it just
does welcome to the agenda gun control
and you may naturally think of the
United States and the frequent death of
citizens they're here in Europe gun
control is of an entirely different
order but regulation is still vital on
Wednesday Parliament's internal market
committee will vote on amendments to
proposed revisions of the EU firearms
directive tightening and clarifying the
rules under which citizens can acquire
guns and rifles including who precisely
and what for effective deactivation of
weapons and information exchange big
days for two of euros big car makers
Volkswagen and Renault they're coming
for a hearing to Parliament's admissions
committee and we'll be joined by Japan's
Mitsubishi thoughts are bound to turn to
vw's diesel emissions fixing scandal but
also to the way forward through more
rigorous emissions testing will be a
vote on the interim report on the
inquiry into measuring systems in the
car sector talking of emissions it's all
about the air we breathe it's reckoned
400,000 Europeans die prematurely every
year from illnesses related to poor air
quality more ambitious national caps by
2030 are in the pipeline controlling
pollutants much of which coming from
cars Parliament's environment committee
will vote on measures agreed recently
with member states not enough of a
revolution same nem EPS but improvements
nonetheless and now for some other items
on the parliamentary agenda how to
counteract anti-eu propaganda from third
countries think Russia here for example
members of the Foreign Affairs Committee
will consider ways within the e use
communication strategy on Monday there's
a vote on Tuesday don't be a parade of
slow back ministers during the week
starting tuesday presenting their
priorities for the six month EU rotating
presidency which is just started not
least the big informal summit in
bratislava in September on the
you post brexit members of the transport
committee meet to vote on three key
elements of the fourth railway package
transforming its hope Europe's rail
network it follows negotiations with
member states including opening markets
to create an eu-wide railway area from
cop21 to cop 22 climate conferences of
course most recent in Paris the next in
Morocco in November on Monday
environment committee members will meet
to discuss Parliament's position on
advancing the co2 reduction targets from
Paris and finally where next for the
eurozone after Briggs it there where big
expectations that the Euro would take a
dive following Britain's referendum
decision to leave the EU in the event
the Euro remains stable and the British
Pound took the day there be discussions
about a tighter eurozone including a
budget on Monday finance ministers from
six countries will arrive to discuss the
desirability or advisability of a
eurozone budget to buffer the Euro
against shock and that's it for some of
the highlights in Parliament's coming
agenda enjoy the week
three